اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من القدس المحتله
اهلا بكم الجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد مقتل ضابط
وجندي اليوم ما يرفع عدد قتلاه الى
124 منذ بدايه العمليه البريه ووسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه تقول ان اعداد العسكريين
الجرحى وفق قوائم المستشفيات اعلى بكثير
مما ينشره الجيش في حين اعلنت كتائب
القسام استهداف ف مبنى يتحصن فيه عدد من
الجنود الاسرائيليين في جحر الديك وايقاع
بين قتيل
وجريح اصابه الزميل وائل الدحدوح مراسل
قناه الجزيره خلال تغطيته قصفا استهدف
مدرسه حيفا في خان يونس ومناشدات عده
لاجلاء مصابين من المكان ومحاصرين من
بينهم مصور قناه الجزيره سامر ابو
دقه بعد لقائه بمسؤولي الاحتلال مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي يقول ان المرحله
المقبله في الحرب ستركز على استهداف قياده
حماس واطلاق سراح باقي المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين ونتنياهو يؤكد ان الحرب
ستستمر حتى هزيمه حماس في حين دعا وزير
التراث الاسرائيلي الى احتلال قطاع غزه
بالكامل شهداء وجرحى في قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف مدرسه تؤوي نازحين في خانيونس
جنوبي القطاع وجيش الاحتلال يقول انه
استهدف بنى تحتيه لحماس على الحدود مع مصر
في وقت قال في تقييما للاستخبارات
الامريكيه ان نصف الذخائر التي استخدمتها
اسرائيل كانت قنابل غير
ذكيه وفي الضفه الغربيه نجاه ثلاثه
مقاومين فلسطينيين من قصف بمسيره
اسرائيليه على مركبتهم في نابلس وقوات
الاحتلال تواصل اقتحاماتها لمدن وبلدات
عده كما قامت بتفجير وهدم منزلين لاسيرين
في قريه عريف جنوبي نابس الى
اللقاء